sim petara começou a disputa loirinha
morena e jogando na boca a ruivinha
pretinha beijo na boca
a fiel e amante beijo na bola vem
jogando hoje em salvador mas todas sem
jogar hoje vencedor aquele que se junta
a elas causam imagine ela é justa e se
junta a elas causa imaginem se juntarem
segurar a quem se quer é quem tem já há
quem não tem como matar e aí a galera
que assistiu o canal está tudo bom com
você ou não
hoje é o dia que abre as inscrições do
meu curso inclusive agora já está aberta
as inscrições link está aqui na
descrição do vídeo é só clicar para se
inscrever mas antes você sair comprando
que não duvido que tem gente que é doido
que vai para a internet quer ficar
comprando vou explicar bem direitinho
como vai funcionar o que vai ter vai ter
uma parada vai três pessoas que
comprarem o curso vão gravar comigo pro
meu canal gravar o canal da pessoa
também não é sorteio tá não é sorteado é
só depende de você que tiver fazendo
curso vai aprender tá pensando em um
nome para dar o curso vai ter seu nome
legal ora pelo curso a criatividade de
criação tinha o seu nome foto nome mas
só dá nome para alguma coisa é difícil
dá nome pra qualquer coisa é difícil
quem tem cachorro só como é que é passar
tanto tempo a botar o nome do cachorro
york batismo cachorro bodhi que totó eu
se fosse um cachorro não fosse a copa eu
ia ficar muito pois os cachorros de
filme vai buscar colocar jogar bolinha
cachorro pega a bola ele é spaic
o spac está feliz você joga grave não do
cachorro é totó pede a totó eu olhar pra
cara de sidónio falar assim mas é [ __ ]
mesmo cara bota meu nome de totó que vai
buscar papa e minha mãe não sei se tinha
criatividade para não machucar ela
escolheu tudo sul chung un-chan edelvan
ou chama harison que chama a vida e
outro chama desgosto vulgo o windows
então resolvi a história para ficar
simples eu vou ter o nome do curso de
cursos é um curso do windows o cabo e o
curso está aí pra você e esse ano foi um
ano sensacional para mim que esse ano e
10 milhões de inscritos aprendendo tudo
que eu aprendi e conseguir fazer um ano
tudo o que eu tinha feito em seis anos
juntando todas em conhecimento e botando
tudo em prática em 2017 eu cresci seis
anos em um nome sentindo juscelino
kubischek foi isso é dom é coisa
deus nasceu com você você nasceu para
brilhar não foi amigos eu aprendi que eu
expliquei tudo no passado você pode
assistir pra você quer viver disso que
tem por que investir na internet quer
viver disso você quer sair o tubo e não
até você meio que quer ser porque você
quer a gente o seu artista que quer
saber mexer na internet para impulsionar
seu artista você quer cantou quer saber
impulsionar sua música quer saber fazer
suas coisas crescer é saber como é que
eu gravo como é que eu divulgo é dito
como eu aprendi a cantar como eu aprendi
a atuar como eu perdi minha timidez como
estimular a criatividade tem tudo
explicadinho lá no curso para você
provar um negócio muito especial bem
interessante é como estimular a
criatividade como fazer sua cabeça pegar
a engrenagem para poder ter uma idéia
toda hora que o maior problema eu vou
gravar sobre o que é o que eu falo o que
contar assim se chama bloqueios etapa
você não tá conseguindo agora quando se
estimula a criatividade quando se está
aqui a engrenagem está rolando toda hora
vem idéia toda hora eu ensinei isso lá
no qual ensinam as técnicas de
associação também para você criar uma
história eu inclusive lá no curso numa
aula que eu fiz eu criei um lá eu já
gravei este vídeo aqui para o youtube
você vai ver esse vídeo e lá no curso
vai falar [ __ ] foi assim que ele
criou esse vídeo eu lá na hora foi
inventando as coisas já foi a nota ano
já foi mostrando como é que eu faço pra
armazenar zte falei que ia gravar é
realmente grave um vídeo apostar já aqui
no canal mas só vai saber quem vai
ensinar técnicas para prender a atenção
da pessoa até o fim do vídeo do começo
ao fim do vídeo entendeu machuquei mas
no curso mas como é que uma nota as
idéias como é que oo é que o parto das
idéias que eu anotei pouca coisa maior
para deixar mais engraçado é que a nota
a idéia de uma foto engraçada o
instagram pareceu está grande no curso e
também por um interessante é como tratar
cada rede social e tratando cada rede
social do modo que ela deve ser tratada
ela cresce uma forma diferente fica
muito melhor pra você divulgar o seu
vídeo no youtube ou seu produto é de
contar técnica que eu criei por aí que
não adianta também só para aprender a
fazer o vídeo o vídeo fica bom ficar
fora e não tem ninguém pra assistir esse
vídeo por isso é importante você saber o
funcionamento do instagram do twitter do
snec chefe do facebook a junção dessas
coisas que põe te ei cri they em contato
para interessante tem tipo eu tenho um
tipo neymar de cada rede social com
pessoas que sabem mexer em cada rede
social que eu mostro pra você e esse
curso é muito importante para quem
viver de internet porque quer ganhar
dinheiro com isso que quer fazer
publicidade na internet essas coisa é
conhecer o seu público isso é muito
importante conhecer o seu público é o
segredo de cada um
lá no curso vou fazer não se identificar
o seu público você saber o que cada
pessoa quer que cada pessoa média vai
ter um cara fazer um curso todo o
youtube vai passar nem vai ser comigo
isso é que o massa desse curso
tem coisas que eu sei mas eu não sei
explicar porque eu aprendi na marra eu
aprendi na olhando-o pesquisando me
[ __ ] errando acabando com a minha voz
acabando com sabe tem professores vai
explicar isso você vai ter um professor
de uma professora de música pra você
quer fazer paródia que até após boa quer
aprender um pouco de tom para poder
cantar sua própria música vai ter um
cara que dá a dica número é tão caro vai
falar sobre o amor que eu falo mas é o
cara que é profissional e vai
complementar entendeu não ser só aquela
coisa eu tô falando de coisas que eu
aprendi na marra mas de repente não sei
explicar o cara que é formado nisso vai
confirmar que estou falando é que eu
faço os memes em nas coisas que eu faço
minhas paródia como é como é que eu faço
a minha paróquia muita gente quer saber
como é que eu faço a minha paróquia no
curso vai ter desde o começo do processo
criativo de quando eu tô cantarolando a
música até a paróquia finalizado eu
queria assistir essa [ __ ] desse curso
eu comecei como é ter me roubado
tambacounda edição audição é [ __ ] porque
amor maior erro de quem gosta fazer um
exemplo o vlog é não saber fazer direito
porte lá o cara vai ensinar você até
botar microfone caísse na oscar a você
quer fazer um conteúdo mais felipe
castanharo na qualidade não queria fazer
paródia não sei cantar vai ter a mulher
já falei mulher do canto que vai fazer a
está você fazer a a ai ai
andam você fazer suas limitações também
atenta com ele o mais importante é o faz
me rir não é todo mundo que quer entrar
na internet quer ganhar dinheiro com a
internet eu quero me ver e ter nossos
youtuber o educou off comprou a porsche
panamera o índice tem um jaguar dannias
uma mercedes felipe neto com promoção
esses em outubro estão ganhando dinheiro
quero ganhar dinheiro com isso também
vai ter ao de monetização no youtube
também precisa aprender como mexer no
seu dinheiro do youtube a tratar bem sua
publicidade sozinha eu quando tinha uns
200 mil inscritos já lá no começo eu já
saí do meu estágio de informática para
viver de internet eu não imaginava isso
pra mim e pra minha cabeça com 30 anos
estava regular sendo computado a
barbonos espinho sair mas não isso votou
hoje eu graças a deus tenho dinheiro às
24 milhões de inscritos na internet
barrigudo coisa ia saindo tem tem
mas não tem problema agora que todo
mundo quer saber quanto é que vai custar
este curso e fala pra mim o roubo fala
pra mim quanto vai sugar do brasileiro
que essa galera falando que está
chegando mais uma forma de ganhar a [ __ ]
que pariu a esse curso vai ter 70 aulas
70 aulas se você por modo vai que a
apostila pra você e apostila pra [ __ ]
final do curso intensificar tem
certificado esse curso tem a edição
iluminação canto teatro se você vai
pagar a cada um desses cursos quem já
foi atrás sabe então vai custar quanto
esse teu e vamos dizer é um mil reais
vai custar 497 reais à vista dá pra
fazer em 12 vezes 12 da média de 50
reais por bem isso aqui é um
investimento é pra você canalha eu
fiquei feliz bem assim quando ele foi
fazer os caras te falar eu sei que tal
tem que ser tal falei mas minha galera
não comprando um compra se focar assim
vão baixar esse peso como vão votar por
o custo-qualidade tem vão votar agora
que todo mundo o que a galera consiga se
acesso pra galera se você gastar 400
adeptos em gastar 400 metros seteais e
conseguir de volta com o trabalho que
você vai fazer depois discurso que eu
lhe desejo muita sorte
que você tenha um retorno de volta e que
deus abençoe você a se disso e henrique
que é isso que eu quero que todo mundo
seja quero que todo mundo olha passou a
me fala assim ao fulano africano
a mostra não eu quero que fulano fique
mais rico ainda expondo de dinheiro
quero que o filho falando brigue pelo
dia do pai de tanto rir e eu desejo
quero muito que dê certo que você faça
esse curso que você está em deus que é
isso que eu quero eu quero pra vocês é
que o que fazer por vocês é o melhor que
eu posso fazer eu fiz um curso com muito
carinho a assistir depois as aulas e é
para a sensacional feliz é uma
realização próxima inscrever no curso é
o primeiro link na descrição do vídeo tá
lá curso do isso clique no link você vai
se faz tudo direitinho não é um cadastro
faz bem direitinho faz com calma faz
direitinho embora o seu nome e não botar
pilha induta porque o sistema bloqueia a
compra se você botar pillay do bota cor
diferente do bota tudo direitinho é doce
para pagamento em boleto cartão tal você
vai comprar o cartão dá para dividir em
12 no boleto à vista
eu acho que eu não sei veja lá a
inscrição fica aberta até sexta feira só
tá segunda sexta sexta feira encerrou
ninguém se inscreve na primeira turma é
limitada não quero encher demais então
já corre se você quiser logo que você
acaba antes de sexta a zaga não aceitam
se apressar para não perder sua vaga
pode ficar ninguém manhã e falar com o
pai é importante o curso tem garantia de
sete dias o que acontece você assiste o
curso depois da chamada de liga porque
você morrer não você fica com cuspo sete
dias vai sair o primeiro módulo tema
assistir o primeiro módulo a ficar com
ele consegue e gostei
ótimo é nóis formula investir no youtube
investir nas redes sociais ganhar
dinheiro com isso não gostou pega seu
dinheiro de volta e aí que nem eu vou
escolher três pessoas do curso que
voltar sempre assistindo quem comprar o
curso vai entender vai ter uma parada
aqui vocês vão fazer os testes vão
gravando e eu vou ficar assistindo eu
vou poder assistir os vídeos que a
equipe vai selecionar os melhores muito
assistiam escolher 32 crianças pessoas
papá e vou pegar essas pessoas para
fazer vir no meu canal comigo vou fazer
no lugar delas também com elas e de
qualquer lugar do brasil pode ser do
acre pode ser da manaus a rondônia o
fortaleza qualquer lugar a viagem paga
sou eu os pedais o irão comigo sorriu só
tomar banho nem vocês se esfregar que
também não ficar estragando os outros
limpam clique no link da inscrição se
inscreve no curso é nóis vai gostar
muito massa valeu e barrichello já note
se o seu caderno taxa de retenção coisa
importante será que já tem canal de tudo
você tem certeza até que vai te assiste
então mas com esses exercícios
a gente vai chegar lá o humorista da
cabeça dele da voz
aquele objeto que o humorista tem essa
forma essa coisa boa que é observar as
coisas e depois de um tempo lapidar
essas coisas e editar é você escolher o
melhor que você tem ou seja você começa
a tirar o que não presta e guardar o que
prestam a abla a a olha a diferença
agora é que a gente vai ligar o softbol
eita ela falar um pouco de técnicas de
como reter a atenção da sua audiência a
sua cabeça começa a virar uma engrenagem
que começa a pegar e tem idéias para
poder fazer piada pra poder fazer graça
olha os seus analytics
quando você entra nessa tela aqui por
exemplo das redes sociais mais
importantes e organize seu filho também
não deixe tudo bagunçado nunca agora que
a gente já aprendeu como estruturar uma
piada agora aprenderá rechear essa piada
né inclusive você pode usar e chegar bem
pertinho da câmera assim a co
eu não sei sem engraçado precisa saber
você usando esses três métodos você
consegue sim que embaixo vai ter o
arquivo pdf para se fazer o download
para você usar o seu tema é você e
treinando pra estimular a sua
criatividade ela não é comediante ela
não faz piadas com a estrutura de pedra
quem está falando mas se contraste delas
e delas é super sincero na cara de pau e
tudo mais torna ela naturalmente
engraçada só pra você não se frustrar eu
tô falando isso entendeu e também não é
um bicho de sete cabeças é legal você
tem pontos para que você saiba o que
você vai falar entender ou esse aqui um
exemplo bem princípio tinha anotado para
fazer o da cocaína a um vídeo sobre
irmãos mas peraí
além de me assistir na prática que
editando esse vídeo eu tenho um
propósito do exercício pra você que tipo
de público que quer conquistar que tipo
de público é que leva a vida inteira a
lei vai ficar aí vamos fazer agora está
pegando o curso já só o filezinho então
faz tudo isso que eu pedi que vai te
ajudar tá tamo junto até a próxima aula
pai
valeu e